[Music]
greg is with us in maryland hi greg
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for having me uh just was
scrolling through the radio first time
listener
and i was like man this guy just kind of
jives he makes sense so i'm calling i
need some advice what i have going on is
i uh recently have tried to downsize and
do everything i can
going from a car loan to a small honda
civic
late model with you know tens of
thousands of tens of thousands of miles
on it so and no payments
what i'm trying to do though is clear
debt
with my home it's the only thing left i
owe
on but it's 250 000 dollars
and i'm trying to figure out long term
is it better for me to invest the money
that i've cleared up with paying off my
car loan and credit credit cards and use
that money towards paying
on my home loan or do i invest that more
to my retirement at work
that's a great question and uh welcome
to the show thank you appreciate you
listening in uh so the process that we
teach on the show is called the baby
steps and it's the proven plan that dave
was just talking about with financial
peace this is the plan inside a
financial piece and so baby step one
thousand dollar starter emergency fund
baby step two clear all of your consumer
debt using the debt snowball sounds like
you're done with consumer debt right
right so baby step three is building up
a three to six months uh emergency fund
of expenses do you have that in place
i do not okay so that would be your next
step right now is to stack up that money
as fast as possible uh three to six
months if your income is really stable
you may lean three or if you want a
little more you can lean towards six and
once you're done with that you move on
to baby step four which is where we
start investing and the investing looks
like this
fifteen percent of your household income
going into retirement tax advantage
retirement accounts like a company 401k
a roth ira things of that nature then
you move on to college savings then you
move on to paying off the house so if
you're saying hey should i be investing
more or paying off the house right now
once you've got that emergency fund
you're investing 15 percent then i would
use any extra money to pay off the house
early once you've done that you've got a
paid for house you're in baby step 7 and
that's where you can go hog wild you can
invest like crazy because you have all
the income in the world so that's the
plan
yeah so it sounds like then investing at
15 once you meet that margin or that
barrier first
then move on to okay anything additional
is what you're going to use to do
additional principal payments on the
house exactly yeah
exactly you got this stuff man that was
quick yeah you you you dialed it in fast
that's exactly and here's the reason
okay
what we've run is we've run over 30
years of doing this we've run a
bazillion different actual life
situations and some hypothetical case
study ideas and said okay we're going to
take someone with this income at this
age and here's how to work this income
at this age and 15
is a healthy amount but it doesn't drain
you down so far that you get to do
nothing on the house
um i mean you could have said it we ran
some scenarios at 20 back in the day
when we were developing this system we
ran some scenarios at 10
but the 10 the retirement was too anemic
and the 20
the amount of money we had to throw at
the house was too anemic anemic and so
it ended up landing to where you'll be a
multi-millionaire if you follow this
process exactly because you will have
built millions of dollars into your 401k
and you'll have paid for house and that
paid for house would be worth half a
million to a million and so um it sounds
like in your case anyway and so that's
that sets you up to do all of this all
of this is outlined in the book that we
did that's a number one bestseller for a
decade it's on the best seller list
almost every week
it's called the total money makeover and
it's the baby steps on steroids it shows
you every nuance every question every
little detail about the baby steps what
to do next what to do next what to do
next and so on so hold on kelly i'll
pick up we'll give you a copy of that as
a new listener merry christmas we
appreciate you
joining us